fanatics heartbreak never seen a
professional game this close the Taipei
assassins winning world's 2012
Albus knocks Luna is incredible underdog
run mean underdog doesn't mean B in
Ella's own dad a surrendering his jacket
general jacket these are just some of
the iconic moments we've witnessed at
the League of Legends World
Championships over the past seven years
so now that the Sun has set on world's
2017 we look back on the most iconic
moments in League of Legends world's
history
of all the iconic stories to emerge from
the League of Legends World
Championships a few are as memorable as
the Taipei assassins run in 2012 the
Taiwanese outfit became overnight
sensations not only for their incredible
play but for decisively overcoming
arguably the three strongest teams at
the tournament in a series of
history-making upsets this is when
assassins ruled the world
heading into the 2012 World Championship
everyone's eyes were fixed on a pair of
teams to win it all there was Moscow 5
the CIS juggernaut who had dominated the
scene thanks to their innovation and
aggression and Korea's azubu frost a
team whose fearsome reputation caused
opposing teams and their fans across the
world to quake in their boots this
fanfare was not the case for the Taipei
assassins in fact they were a massive
question mark heading into the
tournament a total Dark Horse they're
all but non-existent experienced against
international competition caused many to
view them with uncertainty and although
they had utterly dominated their home
region thanks to strong team
coordination and creative play it was
unknown how that would translate against
the world's best on league's biggest
stage but as we all know assassins work
best with the element of surprise as
champions of their region the Taipei
assassins were seated directly into the
playoff bracket and their first opponent
wasn't going to be an easy one
they were slated to face Korea's second
representative the intimidating najin
sword who had steamrolled their group
while TPA were coming in cold led by Lau
toys why Ken and his now legendary
Orianna game 1 was a statement of intent
proving that the Taipei assassins
weren't going to back down against
anybody
oh yeah just the reactor that was he
gets a second so it's gonna get dropped
as well that's gonna be Coco picking up
but once you get stripped down
Duncan the admin a triple tail for the
baby an awful evil place they just
wanted to catch the ariana hopes were a
gain in a game toys it's just reading up
a mark that's gonna be a deterrent that
could easily take it everything off the
back of this one honestly Gigi's Giver
thank you take one against that game too
started out with Naja in my media to
jump in the capital strikes up budgets
get the pickup on him should be out of
finishing Wolfpack news gonna tank this
one up and it's gonna be prey there fix
up there Gail but the assassins clawed
their way back into it with some
ferocious team fighting new balls don't
be very low that watch he's gonna get
dropped us an Oracle down noble feet
while they catch what's one song song
gets dropped as well this is a great
turnaround by type assets agree it's and
the taipei assassins superior map
control team fight execution and
coordination overwhelmed of their korean
adversary magic so pull this way back
they need to keep this fight up they
need to or they will be out to disarm it
Charlie no consignment doesn't get the
whole eggs on the back of that one and
nothing solid me Jason could that be
side by assassin going through that
grossing for the next five gg
assassin surprising everyone [ __ ]
themselves in the sweep over najin
caught the world's attention the Taipei
assassins passionate celebrations and
infectious energy captivated viewers
just as much as their unexpectedly high
level of play said earlier you can only
be as good as the competition you're
playing against well GPS kind of proved
us wrong there DBAs jungle true
importance I mean what's this is only a
la-z-boy waiting to compel down yeah Wow
the wind brought cautious optimism to
their new fans there was still much work
to be done why because Taipei assassins
next opponent was going to be an even
bigger test the love of our Hatem
moscowfive
taking down a tournament favorite like
Moscow five would be no easy task and
after getting torn apart in the first
game of the series
the obvious question was whether or not
TPA were up to the challenge
but that question was answered
definitively in Game two on ghost you
can lock them down with the turrets damn
that gets out of that and it's just huge
pressure from Taipei assassins right now
Darien is however able to clean up a few
kills for his team it's now three two
three four two three now finally the
last Auto Attack and double kill for
toys CAS on the moscowfive
they're gonna gain some huge ground here
as they turn moscowfive face in to
shambles moscowfive not exactly
flustered but I think this is the first
time we have seen them not be able to
answer a strategy toys just back down to
his team and it's gonna be that second
at first Nexus turret the second Nexus
turret then Nexus now a game three
moscowfive forced to defend on the
fountain and it's going to be a huge
matchup your first semifinal match going
into a fest of three between Taipei and
Moscow five in a deciding third game the
Taipei assassins continued their
onslaught by mixing up their strategy
focusing on objective control instead of
teamfights and by the 20-minute mark
they had a 5 to 0 tower lead over Moscow
5 and I'm surprised actually they played
it as a split push but it's actually
working out and Bouldin by their sizable
gold lead the assassins went for Moscow
fives jugular the turret goes down Terry
gets caught out he can't even alter the
crescendo stopping them from using the
abilities diamond price goes down the
inhibitor is open the double kill comes
out fast on five looking very grim right
now taipei assassins look to take down
the last nexus pair and they will drop
pods got five for the league of legends
championship playoffs and would you look
at that the shears the yells at the look
of relief ball makes at the same time on
their faces taipei assassins for the
first team to make it to the world final
after two dramatic upsets the taipei
assassins had made it to the finals only
to have to face the final boss azubu
frost who had been living up to their
terrifying reputation
into a push lane instead of as only
comes illusion from behind the dust
bringers out so he has the speed Tyrande
died here's the 3d one but the counter
it won't be in the turn is right now he
could turn this around shine comes out
with a kill in a 3d one situation to run
out like bunny goes out Brogan ultimate
it's gonna be so nice out left but rapid
now is it now Luke is in that destroy
the opposition grandpa's gonna sucks out
they have super minions coming up the
midline this could well be the end at
today's typical that's the ace that is
the game azubu frost there in the final
it was going to be a slugfest the dark
horse that had toppled two Titans
enroute to the finals against the
expected champions but the Taipei
assassins did not care for expectations
armed with steadfast self belief and
backed by a legion of ravenous
supporters they charged into the game
coming around the side they've got -
here comes a MooMoo coming around the
side she's heading towards it nothing
going up though I think Sean might go
down before they get a chance to finish
it up
Oh enough slightly coming down the side
there they're gonna be act is going to
go about that money
he takes both articles open can they
turn it off the wound just more borax
will he get the slowdown studies gonna
be other take the turns up they are
going to go this one take you down yeah
[Applause]
however azubu frost would begin to turn
things around off the back of a
now-famous Quadra kill by rapid star on
Karthus you don't become an apple
bourbon isn't enough toys and slowly you
get drop these down to an egg right now
about ten flowers inside but the damage
really coming from his room though at
the back
Oh
eventually the Koreans would seal game
without the ball shy get it before
killed 42 minute victory despite giving
up the lead in the series the Taipei
assassins would bounce back in Game two
thanks to Sun lil balls Quan posed
jungle dr. mundo which caught as Ubu
frost completely off guard
madlife warning voted for the cleaver
he's got a clean run in he's crashed in
he gets exhausting it's the lead by my
life but they're gonna turn it down
that's gonna be first button his BB up
picks it up once a game here we see
Joyce Mitchell's Anderson teleport room
toys will the paint not when I never
rappers back to the cattle shed to the
reverb let's go
because they're gonna try to get out
website dropping stars gonna get drunk
and they take shine up as well they do
but Susie cannibals getting involved
hasten the home we have walked off a
group go jogging
which Bobby's ex no one's coming up
well take Game two in Game three - I saw
Rihanna would be a triumphant return
away shot boom that's gonna be an hour
go bad for toys we're gonna pull to the
gallon slightly with the ball on it he's
gonna jump back off we're gonna get this
right
what might say assassinating azubu frost
it is surrender
they knew the game was over azubu frost
they just wanted to get out of the next
game that could be a smart call they
knew that lingering in that game was
only going to demoralize them so they
decided to end it early the taipei
assassins were one went away from the
unlikeliest of world titles and in game
4 they showed azubu frost no mercy he
forced the way in a time at life is
completely out of position he's gonna
try and back off from here and he's
trying to teleport him who's not gonna
get out trapped he is trapped as he
managed to escape it though with that
will that little picture yes bottom he
has my eyes
it kills me give it to toys GJ is
feeling very confident right now because
Oh big fight up top that pressure on
towards my life that might be true shout
temple are getting straight in there the
lunar what what pops up up
absolute zero go stop Stanley take it
loose that has the back way now Templar
get drop by mistake
can they turn the aggression though we
go twice oh here comes the time
there comes is the short wave going to
come out though then suddenly pulls the
ball and slam these Manny's gonna try
and come across loud tempers gonna get
Gortari
he will go down eventually his toys the
picks up the Gila cane the group was
exhausted Taipei assassins are gonna
continue diving would move with a lunar
ultimate is going to walk away from that
baby
Sushil Arad makes that work with total
map control and a 17 K gold lead the
Taipei assassins went for the killing
blow
[Applause]
they had done it the Taipei assassins
had an fatica Li taken down three of the
world's best teams to become a world
champions they took down the cream of
the crop nation-- sword looked on stop
blood of group stage Moscow flat was the
favorites coming into the tournament
who's the first one against the
champions of Korea and then take three
games in a row the Taipei assassins run
has become something of a legend it
comes from a time when league of legends
was still growing and theirs was easily
one of the most exciting storylines to
grace the game up to that point sure
looking back on the games now we can see
how far the competitive scene has come
the macro decisions team fighting and
execution are far more developed today
but the Taipei assassins story at Worlds
2012 still embodies the amazing spirit
of league's early days the passion the
fun the triumphant underdog how can you
not love that
[Applause]
[Music]
that is just awesome
one more hit championship hopes can be
made or destroyed by the smallest of
margins and few teams have learned this
more dramatically than oMG and fnatic
did at the 2014 World Championship
one more hit is all fnatic needed but
instead it was one of the closest games
in world's history this close but
instead it was heartbreak for fnatic
Group C of the 2014 World Championship
was a race for second korea's champions
samsung blue were heavily favored to
take first but china's OMG europe's
fnatic and north american lmq were all
contenders for the other playoff spot
meaning that every single win mattered
because right now
quarterfinal hopes are still alive for
every single squad it was day three for
the group fnatic had already lost
oMG earlier in the tournament
but a win in the rematch would put the
victor in prime position to move on to
the next round
74% of you said a fanatic will walk away
with the win so mirroring the sentiment
frog analyst desk as expected the game
was an absolute barn burner with both
teams going back and forth will be left
someone gets it in this middle and there
is a stone covered in but you see lo
fleeing stuck around long enough they're
actually gonna turn to inspector dead
parties that make his doctor to survive
this one but he does get the kill on the
way out I guess
it's over sash we are so far away from
that right now and OMG is right on the
front doorstep pie to the face of
reckless is cyanide dodges out on that
one
and it looks like he will be getting
popped by the death Mart he goes down to
Cathy and surprise can finish coke going
but he flashes over the wall sound with
a beautiful relentless pursuit to save
himself as well open absecon pushing
strain of that Midland barn is gonna go
down here for oMG but they may lose it
inhibitor for it they've got a recall
though on financing I've already got the
turret the inn is going down that's the
trade that fanatical brothers say we'll
take it watch this flank from OMG though
go-going is behind them I just don't
think the timing syncs up right fnatic
has a good chance of getting away from
this one unscathed for them this is the
final do you have to take it's gonna be
cool going it's reckless yet no chance
to use pretty much anything and it
didn't matter because they did get it on
him so a speck a hairy hurt here
bubbling goes in gets the hit up he's
stuck but he jumps again tries to go for
black aid they've lost now so as and
reckless how will oMG move off of this
because they still have to guard their
base we said that oMG needed to put up a
fight before inhibitors all go down and
at the very worst case they'd have to do
it before that third inhibitor is a god
and he's getting the kill as well that
gives in the rock plate an OMG seemed to
have an opening and charged fanatics
base but expec a held fast repelling the
Chinese squad's aggression XD five
minutes to get
the Nexus turrets OMGs Nexus turrets are
down don't be very cool eat the shot he
goes down
you see but it doesn't matter with oMG
on the run and most of fnatic in pursuit
so as made the decision to teleport to
the top lane enter the enemy base and
begin hitting of the Nexus
to be the hero the wrinkles dominates
let's go mentees only together
whoa
as reckless stalled recalls and killed
two members of 'omg expec a and cyanide
joined the scramble putting everything
they had into omg's nexus go going and
loveling put everything they had into
saving their Nexus each hit bluffing at
a closer and closer to winning the game
it came down to the wire
it still is start trying to get in
left and right the top witness to come
up with their Nexus saved OMG surged
back into the game because if they got
into another fight brother down two
inhibitors they may lose they're trying
to use this one death hammer of Donna to
end it but decisively winning the next
big team fight to win the game and crush
fnatic beneath them it's hard to imagine
that a game which was well past the hour
market came down to a single hit the
clip has been broken down replayed and
analyzed countless times she needs to
stay with the grief way to guarantee hit
stay alive for longer while the benefit
of hindsight has made us realize several
things such as so as is Sonia's being
available cyanide and neglecting to use
his locket of the iron Solari and a
number of other minor mistakes caused by
the immense pressure of the situation
one thing is for sure the moment is
unforgettable
it's filled we'll start trying to get in
inhibitor spawning left and right the
top one is still come it was tragic and
triumphant all at once no matter which
side you were rooting for this clip is
iconic because it embodies exactly what
world's is all about it's a battle on
the edge a battle of wills where teams
can push each other to the very limit
even if that limit is just one the top
still come up but oMG also stopped their
Nexus you ever seen a professional game
this close down the stretch these days
in the world of league of legends every
wildcard team can be a threat not to be
taken lightly
we've seen the gigabyte Marines push
team solomid to the limit pain gaming
make their mark during the 2015 World
Championship and even Alvis knox luna
reached the quarterfinals of the 2016
World Championship hey guys there from
wild carp and they have told you before
being underdog doesn't mean being a
loser but this wasn't always the case
back in the early years few gave the
wild card teams a second thought they
were write-offs teams to be brushed
aside by the powerhouses of Korea China
North America and Europe
for free wins that is until the 2014
World Championship they're a team that
wasn't supposed to win anything changed
everything with one simple upset taking
the first step to earning wildcard teams
the respect they deserved
this is how the storyline of Group D
went kaboom September 28th the final day
of action for Group D at the 2014 League
of Legends World Championship the day
before European LCS champions Alliance
shocked the crowd playing a perfect game
against the favored Korean team najin
white shield five seconds following that
impressive victory Alliance was on track
to lock in their place in the
quarterfinals the hype and expectation
for the European super team was at a
fever pitch with only one group game
left for them to play they were set to
face the wild card Brazilian squad
kaboom eSports all Alliance had to do in
order to likely advance was overcome
this one last minor obstacle despite
having shown in pervy over the course of
the tournament kaboom was expected to
lose but this match with alliance marked
their last opportunity to earn a win
defy the odds and prove that IWC teams
deserved a spot at the World
Championship but there is more on the
line than just Brazilian pride North
American fans were heavily invested in
their success as well because if kaboom
could upset Alliance American
representative cloud nine could make it
out of the group with a win over noggin
with no threat of a tie with alliance
otherwise cloud nine would have to beat
najin and play in a three-way tie
breaker to advance not a thrilling
prospect and so the hopes of an entire
region were pinned on to the unlikely
heroes but kaboom did not disappoint as
they caught Alliance off-guard with
their aggression securing early kills to
assert control over the game although
alliance hung in there with kills of
their own over time kabooms pressure
forced them into making
uncharacteristically bad engagement
gets it up here beam if next actually
they're looking for more hills on this
once head-ons over the wall
SAP just misses this could be the next
one that go down that's fine if left
gets over the wall and kaboom goats of
dynamite
what the hell was that project there was
the worst engaged I've ever ever seen
kaboom would only add to the European
squad's misery by taking down their
towers at will extending their gold lead
and tightening their grip over the map
Alliance sought refuge within the safety
of their own base but even those walls
can repel the relentless offensive waves
of tin owns and kaboom
destroyed despite their best efforts to
stall out the game Alliance collapsed
too much on their plate to get thinner
that's the fight
then the control on to left they are
able to take them down Dan Accord very
low
nothing in 410
the Brazilian underdogs emerged
victorious not only becoming the first
wild card team to earn a significant win
at an international tournament but
dramatically changing the face of the
group kabooms part was done now it was
up to cloud 9 to seize the lifeline
they'd been thrown by the Brazilians the
Americans needed to defeat najin in the
final game to advance you couldn't
script it any better right from the
start the match was a back and forth
affair
both teams traded lives towers and map
objectives across 40 minutes but then
cloud 9 began to really turn it up
the Americans did not waste their
opportunity to advance from the group
pacing najin and producing one of the
most iconic sound bites in league of
legends history in one of the most
dramatic reversals of fortune ever
Alliance went from playing a perfect
game to being out of the group in two
fateful games there's a 100% chance
Alliance definitely underestimated that
one the way they picked - the way they
played and three - attitude before the
game like before they played that man
Sir Thomas you know like they're gonna
be kaboom so like we better beat a
Giunta for the three-way attack because
they we're not like fight us again and
things like that you know it's like
[Music]
that's like karma right there for like
looking down and then you know to this
day the tale of Group D at Worlds 2014
is unforgettable because of the bond
forged between cloud 9 and kaboom and
it's long lasting impact on the
perception of wildcard teams in league
of legends but most importantly of all
kabooms humbling of alliance reminded
the world that no victory is ever
guaranteed and that sometimes there is
more to fight for than just trophies
kaboom fought for their pride they
fought for respect and they fought for
each other what more could you ask for
it than that
in underdog doesn't mean being a loser
so
[Applause]
no one has ever expected much from the
International wildcard teams at world's
before 2016 wildcard teams had a
combined record of 4 wins and 28 losses
in the group stage their best
representative came in 2015 when pain
gaming placed last in the group with a
two and four record well played game
here by pain becoming the first
wild-card team to win multiple games at
the world champion of going into Worlds
2016 people weren't really expecting
anything to be different
Brazil's int ze sports were considered
to be the strongest wild-card team that
year but they weren't predicted to make
it out of their group if you're not
familiar with the sea below they are a
slow-paced region and I ain't easy is
one of the slowest takes it meanwhile
Albus knocks Luna qualified for worlds
as an underdog after upsetting Lyon
gaming going for a plus this at night
that alphas knocks Luna I'm making it to
Worlds but ahead of the tournaments
anybody looking to say anything about
the little-known team could point to a
few things they had crushed the LCL in
both spring and summer they had a solid
top and mid lane and their support
Kirill the crit Malafaia
was at one point the top-ranked player
on EU West I mean the crit was often the
reason for both Albus Knox Lunas
victories and defeats his roaming off
meta support picks and loud personality
defined the team for many analysts
trying to predict how they would do in
the group stage but despite his ability
all of them put all the stocks dead last
in Group A our opposing team in Albus
knocks Luna so crumb tell me out here
what are these what is this squad
looking to do against the tournament
favorites I think they're just looking
to last as long as they can at first it
looked as if everyone's predictions were
going to be accurate Albus Knox fell to
the rocks Tigers in a quick bloody game
that saw Roxas ad carry prey a pick up
13
thanks for the other ones and now Smurfs
will fall but scumbag curls feels it
away but that is the eighth inside the
base that should be the game for Rox
Tigers to start their tournament 1 and 0
the tournament favorites stopping
everyone in front of them turning it on
after 10 minutes and laying waste to
Alva stocks
the Tigers were favourites to make it to
the grand finals and everyone was
confident that Albus Knox would meet
their low expectations but in two days
Alvis Knox blew those expectations away
now all the stocks they actually gave us
an exciting kill heavy start to the
tournament up against Rox Tigers of all
team but they weren't able to keep it
under control so to speak in the game
quickly ran away from them after that
donates the kill and sniffs able to
flash away to safety but that was
optimistic despite a rough early game
Albus NOx held fast against clg's
assaults and turned the game around
after CLG overextended another killed
Elvis not they judge makes Mitty look
crit basically soul Rudi in that fight
he's coming back in on the backside of
it what kid sticks adieu he's gone full
HP but five olympus from the CIS region
to deal with a spit you can flash to
save the attempt at faith but by some
time forever forever but simply not
enough suddenly Alvis NOx was in the
driver's seat
and they drove straight into CL cheese
Nexus
in their second game of the tournament
Albus NOx handed counter logic gaming a
shocking defeat Albus knocks Luna really
representing the sea is very very well
here and they played this game straight
up they just outplayed CLG the upset was
huge for Albus NOx but they weren't done
just yet
Albus NOx moved on to play g2 eSports
later that day g2 were faltering looking
for a win after a disappointing opening
to the tournament logic gaming one the
way that CLG wins control strategy
shotcalling and teamwork leads North
America to a 1-0 record at world but
they were still coming off a season as
the absolute best team in Europe despite
g2 s poor play and Albus Knox's shocking
performance against CLG few were ready
to pick the CIS wildcards over the
European champions and this is the
matchup that I'm truly excited for
spring and Miffy facing across from
liqueur and a miracle on paper we have
to be honest venomoth used to smash that
doobie - yes unlike CLG and Rox g2
didn't respect the crit they didn't ban
his legendary brand letting Albus knock
scooped him up for their support
but brand wasn't the only problem every
time g2 tried to disengage from a fight
Kiera's and Nivea put up a wall and
Smurfs poppy charged in to pick up a
stun and almost always guarantee a kill
four-time g2 think they've made it our
life there's the flash bumpy and a wall
interaction or separate paths
the LCL represent have lost you are the
tournament favourites to win four days
later
Albus Knox took another game off of CLG
it was fast and brutal in Albus knocks
effectively for CLG to waste bans on
brand and anivia out of respect
the bans weren't enough though as the
wild-card team went up to a three in one
record in the group stage you need to
prepare to play versus us otherwise you
will lose no matter of yours it went
from you or c2 from an A
we're a big deal now you have to you
have to admit it or lose and then came
the Tigers last time they met just one
week before the Rox Tigers blew Albus
knocks out of the water that should be
the game for Rox Tigers this time Albus
knocks came ready for a fight and praise
go rebel but this
[Applause]
they're actually feeding the rocks
Tigers right now Alvis NOx started the
game aggressively and kept the pressure
up all game taking the fight to the
Tigers again and again crazy blood
thirst
that's exactly what they gave them they
might have enough it's that cord again
it all he wanted to do was fight and the
Tigers crumbled under the pressure
they did
just took down the rocks
Albus NOx made history they were the
first wild card team to beat a Korean
team they were the first wild card team
to make it out of groups they
single-handedly turn the wild card
reputation around that was one of the
best late-game rotations at the very end
they did it the out Mack rode the rocks
Tigers in a late game and you can't take
this away from them this was a 67 almost
a 17 minute game they weren't just
another stepping stone on the way to the
quarterfinals for some Korean team they
were more than even contenders they made
it they qualified even after making it
out of groups liquor it wasn't ready to
trash talk he wanted to acknowledge
every team's play in the group stage and
gave what might be the most
inspirational speech ever given at
Worlds we came here expecting 0-6 we
came here without real preparation we
didn't put camp in Korea and we were
like okay guys we'll just come and play
our game but today today we're in
quarterfinals oh sure and all I want to
say is that hey guys we are from failed
car and they have told you before being
underdog doesn't mean being a loser so
may not have made it past the
quarterfinals but that didn't really
matter they were more than just an
underdog story they were proof that a
wild-card team could be more than a
group filler more than another losing
record in the history of wild card teams
at Worlds albus knox made history by
showing that worlds was a truly
international event
it isn't just about the major regions
it's about everyone who plays league
time
[Applause]
just took down the rock
we knew it was coming and we were warned
but that didn't stop Marcus dyrus Hill's
tear-filled retirement speech from
pulling at our heartstrings in ways a
few league of legends moments can match
I'm really sorry to all my fans
[Applause]
following team solomid final game at the
2015 World Championship shocks a stood
on stage with the TSM veteran for an
interview that would shake the North
American League of Legends scene I
really really respect the energy of the
crowd no matter who they're cheering for
when it's either so as or and it's just
it's all really fun
when someone makes that huge play and
all that energy it's just really
exciting to watch unfortunately
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately on my side land I wasn't
able to plumb when it was mattered and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dyrus was a three-time na LCS champion
whose career had spanned more than five
years one of only two players to attend
all of the first five world
championships and Idol for countless
fans and his illustrious professional
career had come to an end it's only
normal for someone like you who tries so
hard it was best to feel this way in
this particular moment but all these
people really genuinely support you and
there are so many people who do because
you've built up an incredible career
dyrus had started his career with the
epic gamer before moving to TSM and
built his reputation for his play on
aggressive play making picks like singed
Renekton and jacks his tendency to spam
laugh on his signature singed combined
with his quirky personality made him an
instant fan favourite a dreamhack when
we played against triple-a when I was on
epic gamer I was stuck at the tower and
they had a new and irelia trying to
towerdive me at level two and they're
like
lovely Prius I decide the tower I just
was spamming live by 2015
dyrus had shifted to take on a
self-sacrificing role on TSM often
picking tanks or utility champions for
the good of the team and he got camped a
lot now is now level 6 it's not dyrus
this vault this keeps happening but what
do you expect a nice death sentence on
to dyrus that's three kills already man
TSM really just leaving dyrus out to dry
yet again but his willingness to take
one for the good of the team only made
him more of a hero in the eyes of fans
those who had followed him since the
start of the journey who remembered his
years as a dominant carry top respected
and admired his dedication to the team
even at the cost of his own personal
glory
however with his retirement on the
horizon it was not the way fans wanted
him to go thankfully in a crucial game
against gravity in the NA LCS playoffs
dyrus proved he could still put the team
on his back heading into Worlds TSM's
group was challenging but not unwinnable
kt rolster vs team solomid both of these
regions are so far undefeated in the
world championship in either Korea or
North America will end this game 3 and O
across three teams DSM what major
underdogs dyrus ever the great teammate
was back on tanks but the team's
performance was lackluster at best the
European and North American seeds are in
a huge hole that they're about to have
to climb out of in order to take down
Goliath like LGD and KT I think this is
a team the group that has the most fans
behind it because all these teams are
pretty popular but everybody didn't
really know who these guys are and wanna
see their own region do very well and we
don't
really know how well they're gonna do by
the end of the group stage
TSM only put a single win on the board
spelling an early elimination and while
the team now make the one win in the
tournament we still got to see I mean
it's a very very tough group there were
some great teams and ed we got randomly
fantastic early games something they
were another really bad at doing to
Samus wit they were always full banner
they changed that coming in tsm's
performance at Worlds 2015 was not what
fans had hoped it would be and dyrus
felt like he had let his fans down as a
crowd cheered for me I started to cry
because in my mind I played so bad on
that day and I felt like I could have
came so close to getting out of groups
and I could have made it I could have
made it there for my team but I failed
my team and you know going on to the
interview I didn't feel like I deserved
the praise
Tennyson's roster has changed the team
has had its ups and downs but it always
seemed like dyrus would stay forever in
fact as League itself continues to grow
develop and change we can look back at
this as a landmark moment in that
evolution DARS might be a truck Cyrus is
in a 4v1 right now let's see how long he
lasts on this he actually dives into the
fight and he is causing them to water
back off the back side he's only down to
about 20% HP after they have all had the
chance gene that was spell real tryna be
full it was more than a simple
retirement speech it was the end of an
era
dyrus one of the last remaining bastions
of the old guard of League of Legends
hanging up his mouse and front of
legions of adoring fans
whether you cheered for na EU China
Korea or any region it was impossible
not to feel emotional watching one of
league's most respected and decorated
veterans say goodbye everything that's
there it's it's been done and now it's
time to open a new book right now my
story ends here but I still even with me
gone
I still want everyone to support tis
them and all all of my teammates
as tears fell and the crowd chanted
dyrus raised his hand in one final
salute a fittingly iconic send-off to
one hell of a player while dyrus had a
final hurrah at the 2015 all-star game
and has even dipped his toes back in
competitive play with his fellow
retirees on delta fox since that day at
Worlds it has never been quite the same
when we look back on dyrus we remembered
the player who spam laughed on singed
who sacrificed himself for his team and
who until the very end
loved his fans as they loved him I have
nothing but gratitude for you guys and I
wish the best of luck to my teammates
look future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bay da da yo Jen is perhaps one of the
greatest midlaners in league of legends
history and during the course of his
impressive career he earned the nickname
the general for his incredible
leadership and tactical brilliance which
led to various successes on the rift oh
what a great play doing the damage can
he get out though during his time with
samsung blue the general was never seen
on the battlefield without his uniform
long they don't go together at all
the white leather jacket was always
draped over his shoulders and became a
trademark for the Koreans reputation as
a leader and his all business
personality but at Worlds 2014 the
unthinkable occurred and da de found
himself at the center of undoubtedly one
of league's most memorable out-of-game
moments at the beginning of 2014
da da joined Samsung blue the team had
finished in 5th to 8th in the winter
split but their fortune changed with his
arrival as he lifted them to a first
place finish in the spring season
despite finishing a close second in the
following summer season samsung blue
were still considered among the
favourites to lift the summoner's Cup
they won first place in the champions
spring and second place in the champions
summer and earned enough circuit points
to clinch the number one seat for the
green region at Worlds and to be fair
they have to be the favourites to finish
as number one at Worlds as well in the
group stage the Koreans did not
disappoint
only dropping a single game to top the
toughest group of the tournament I think
job done for samsung blue they wanted to
come in for you know and I'm a perfect
record well in the group of
I think they can actually be fairly
happy with the fact that they only lost
the one game we go on to knock oh cloud
9 in the quarterfinals with a 3-1 win
highlighted by some impressive teamfight
coordination orchestrated in large part
by dades leadership he goes down it's
gonna be another go father darling it's
gonna try
this gel pulls it
get it down
that's the blue it bought the truck but
in the semi-finals they found themselves
face to face with a familiar adversary
Samsung white in the summer season blue
had destroyed white 3-1 in the playoffs
[Music]
but at world's white struck back with a
vengeance there's the desiccator watch
College of the bat dot he's trying to
find what he can Jeff gets hit up
there's no feel for him
Jane obstruction did go off but it's
soon his looper is flat out of that
prison he is just knocking down the wall
finding more pills
Adamo for him another aids for Samsung
what booth this joint fight goes wrong a
lot collided Duran Goes Down they are
not able to get too much off of that but
they do get a kill overriding still on
and intend use rod comes in with the
jump that just looks like he is gonna
chew everything up one more hit the
double kill for foil the destiny goes so
mission is everywhere they needed to
spirits solo heart jumped as low in a
matter of seconds a double kill coming
in for pawn it doesn't matter what he's
on the teams are ready and willing to
continue the killed I feel so bad for
Darnay going where he pleases the
[ __ ] hits he's gonna have the
connection the howling gale will pop him
up there's this effort the exhaust and
pontius plops right down forces Hill one
of the biggest stops of all of worlds
right now huge 28 to 3 22 minutes in are
they're really gonna knock it down right
now the quickest in this best-of-five
series and they do not hesitate to drop
the Nexus it's only gonna take 3 Samsung
white finally
after a 3-0 drubbing at the hands of
their sister team Samsung blue exited
the tournament but it's what da day did
in the immediate aftermath of the series
that forever remains in hearts of fans
but it game you know the gloves are on
very much so if your business is
business mentality coming in for them no
way
old generals Jack
da de Wow even with a smile on his face
that is a big moment that is a jacket
daddy never takes off in a classy
gesture the general handed over his
iconic jacket to pon a symbolic way of
admitting that Samsung lights midlaner
hadn't just beaten him he had surpassed
him pon was the next generation and it
was time for da day to pass him the
torch Samsung white would go on to win
world's 2014 and throughout their
triumphant grand final series against
Royal Club the generals jacket was
visible resting over the back of pawns
chair a respectful salute to one of
league's greatest midlaners never takes
off Tim pay respect here for what you
have amazing about you respect it's easy
to watch League of Legends these days
and take the incredible quality of play
for granted they really get
baker's low how much for can they get
the stress come again
more than that it's easy to forget that
it's not just the quality of play that's
grown but the community as well
league of legends always had potential
to be the massive global hit it is now
but it took time to realize that season
one's World Championship was one of the
first times the entire world got to see
truly International League of Legends
competition at the highest level and a
series of clashes between fnatic and
against all authority defined it their
matches set the bar for quality of play
and drew record viewership the dream
arena is packed with over 1200 people at
this point in time we have about 80 to
90 people sitting in front of us right
now really like this place is just crazy
it's like humongous and there's like so
much free stuff is so much to do from
the beginning of season 1 worlds fnatic
and against all authorities seemed faded
to make history together
meeting first in the group stage and
then again in both the upper bracket
finals and the grand finals each time
the two teams faced off they had to play
better than ever before
one-upping each other with a series of
plays that deserve their place in
history the towers got double hits on
him he's surely gonna finish him off
though he's gonna pull he's got the ulti
down but I think that barrel to the
roster a wrist speak fat-bellied in the
face of graciousness oh trying to steal
it so does this go down very quickly
they did quite get the steel over the
eye showers just missed completely it's
gonna get away and I think knew who's
gonna go down actually for nasty will
come out very well on top of that and
that's gonna be a never gonna get
rebirth straight away I think down the
bottom we could see there's also someone
chasing or Gragas on the bottom and
that's gonna be bomber going down
while against all authority would echo
fanatic in their best of one group
encounter the two european teams met
again in the upper bracket final in Game
two
fanatics jungler lorry a cyanide
happenin would put Triple A on notice
with an incredible Baron steel on his
Jarvan the fourth nearly guaranteeing
fnatic the game and series and I'm not
quite sure it is yet the Stila started
and it's grabbed by fnatic as a good
shape for them they see other whites
gonna turn out looks like Kuja already
dead yellow star getting crushed right
now by shushei and the rest and this was
looking so good fnatic right now since
fnatic the winner's bracket finals
they're gonna win that with the other
great models guaranteed top to fnatic
cloves phonetic have not lost a single
game since day one triplet did push
through against team solomid and loser
bracket finals and they are back to
fight for their share of the hundred
thousand dollar total prize purse thirty
two minutes into the second game triple
a head fnatic on the ropes but Melisande
was looking like he was about to escape
the fight with his life that's when
borah yellow star kim did something in
40 and they're gonna turn that fight
around with the stakes so high with so
much on the line yellow star still
stepped up his Ashe arrow instantly
became legendary beautiful job all the
way down the middle
season one worlds plays don't hold up as
well as more recent moments in League of
Legends history but that doesn't mean
they should be forgotten yellow star in
the grand finals of the season one
championship I'm sorry but there's not a
better time to make an epic arrow in a
do-or-die situation it wasn't just the
peak of play at the time it was beyond
what many thought could be done in the
game it was a glimpse of what was to
come
the roaring crowds the high stakes and
of course the plays getting better
and better every year killed and they
even got the pickup on Bay rocks doesn't
actually have to stop pushing right now
they can delay the recalls
[Applause]
they may not hold up but looking at
those plays now fanatic and against all
authority pushed each other so far go to
the other bush with bran missing the
pillar of fire he's just standing in the
null zone flashed over the edge we see
the ultimate from brands coming around
so has tried to do a lot of damage here
moment comes in trying to lay down the
ultimate as well with anivia a great
amount of focus cyanide falls as rammus
and it is going to be too down in that
when his mouth Hart also went down
fnatic it looks like they are going to
coming across fnatic went on to win the
first world's title going to win the
season 1 changes if they can hold on
just fixes will go down to graduates
diplomatic put together against all
authority and fnatic pushed League of
Legends further than anyone had before
[Music]
SK Telecom t1 our perennial favorites at
Worlds each year they qualify if they
aren't the frontrunners to lift the
summoner's Cup they're always in the mix
maybe second seed if you would look past
them as the big favorites for all 2017
since their first world's appearance in
2013 that has always seemingly been the
case but that's not to say they didn't
have their skeptics I know you want to
be on the Korean hype train let's go
follow your code SK I'm thinking about
it thanks coach
no thanks while most panelists at Worlds
2013 failed to predict SK T's triumph
even fewer could have expected just how
hard the Korean hype train would run
over the rest of the world and that hype
train would not only go on to establish
the greatest dynasty esports has ever
seen but usher in the dawn of korean
dominance in international league of
legends ladies and gentlemen the hype
train is real in the hot six summer
championship SKT had dominated securing
a perfect record in the regional
play-off group stage only dropping a
single game heading into the grand
finals
in their showdown with the kt rolster
bullets things did not go as smoothly
the top witness placing Nelson a huge
three-man shockwave piglet on the upside
doing a lot of damage and oh my god SSK
hell no despite another double kill
from piglet it's just not quite enough
on triple kill first score kill going in
the back
what a huge ultimate piglet a little bit
crap crow soared over the wall even the
mid lane helps to pick up acute a few
kills right away impact there we go
double kill for Rio and impact behind
enemy lines trying to get the score the
winner is down he's under turn look at
that a double kill for score there goes
the Nexus gg but SKT would not be swept
aside here we go going for it SKT comes
in immediately takes out a real jumpy on
the cacao he's an expected score and
often not lasting a great fight ultimate
double kill again for faker and it is an
easy easy ace / sk telecom a perfect
days in the Dewar die game 5 SKT would
complete the reverse sweep famously
highlighted by fakers now legendary
destruction of ryu on zed opaque or
maybe in trouble your death Mark Price
the cleanup for you oh look at the boat
the hard-fought victory cemented SKT
status as Korea's top team and punched
their first-ever ticket to Worlds and
their rampage continued there
now pick this gonna be the focus in here
is gonna get melted looking good on top
or balls eyeballs begging man do get it
taken down but Newcombe just gets melty
now that tapped put some good damage
down but make it gets itself the double
sorrow zero he gets caught out he goes
down and that's gonna be tapped for now
he just can't fail to do destroyed the
moment someone gets focused targeted
they're here points are gone that is the
eggs for SK Telecom t1 advantage in this
fight impact gets in he manages to get
the stun at the on one odwin propels up
equalizes going to slow down the
entrance I could have a huge amount
impact is keeping on three members of
TSM the first victim will be expecially
he got the crescendo down but it's not
going to be enough to save them is not
dyrus will be the second victim of the
fight as a double kill for a piglet is
you know flashes over the wall triple
kill as he turns at the wild turtle this
is gonna be the portrait duck pick up
the Quadra kill SKT ended up going seven
and one in the group stage dropping just
one game - oh my god oMG to take out SKT
t1 but SKT quickly made up for it in
their rematch where they pulled off what
is perhaps the most incredible early
gameplay of all time the max range charm
the lock up the knock down the takedown
bengi gets the kill their going is way
too close the exhaust is there but it's
not going to be enough they are gonna
fall one after the other and the I think
I can do but I think I can they really
can't SKT can they're going three turns
and a ruin another kill I stopped at
four and five their goal four six seven
eight inhibitor turned at 12 minutes
oMG could lose their first game here the
12 minute inhibitor is one of the most
dominant plays in League of Legends
history and it set the tone for the rest
of their tournaments but despite their
displays of clear supremacy SKT still
had their doubters what happened last
year the number one seed comes out and
wins the World Championship and everyone
under eights them because because they
came in from an unknown region of course
is speaking of TPA and of course Bears
are here in their stead
I'm just saying the exact same thing was
here here's here's the amazing Korean
team whether it's sword or Frost if you
want to count last year and TPA wins it
all I think bears can just retrace the
steps and again SKT responded to their
critics on the risk of the dragons
descent tidal wave comes in from the
background does manage the cat to Flora
and NL in trouble that was a good
strangle force but NL is down that's a
lot of gamma base damage removed winds
is going to be the second kill of the
fighters how they turn on the floor on
that's going to be a triple kill for
piglet turret
Russia's non-combat items still has
better record in fact ah here comes
faker he is just melted stay basically
hanging around on the sidelines we do
see NL has been caught he's been kicked
back for that they're now dead to rights
now steak will be the next one to fall
who gets a kill to edit its Baker and
piglet picks up his second now wins is
getting chopped down and slaughtered the
background is crushed a tween ace for
SKT and they gonna close this game out
there are two the Nexus turrets got a
hand of SCTV definitely
in the semi-finals a domestic rival
awaited najin black sword Laden gonna
have to try and take him out looking for
something in this myth has managed to
catch our king haku lads at a flash over
the world watch okay has reengaged the
solar flare lost our faith this rain
would throw him up fear they've traded
one for one one for one and what man do
surely will fall actually managed to
walk away for now with ignite ticking
lizards or the barrel coming down now
expression doing very alone man do we'll
finish that one up with his passive name
peaks of the triple they're gonna keep
chasing here but do they have the damage
rate going over towards bacon thank you
we'll walk away from now they chase down
in power all the other side that they're
gonna keep track of him here is he gonna
be able to hold it off there's a fairly
slam add the barrel that day believe you
know
najin pushed SKT to their limits leading
to the tournament's only five game
series with everything on the line SKT
rose to the occasion and smashed their
Korean compatriot up by objectives and
they go for the pick on K Keynes in
trouble he manages to get the plate on
trueshot barrage throws across now
stanchion Dyson has been used not the
sort of the retreat they're trying to
get out here turn impact he's hard to
can I pray pray still alive as the
counter-strike doesn't last a good job
now treatments in trouble he uses the
our kinship board he's secured another
kill as not de-spawn to retreat not make
it some
because stuff expecially Trump still in
trouble and he's a last mano in this one
is if I'm gonna die votes up with him
there is the ace for SKT this is at
least in here this is the big three this
is the final
representing Korea at the Staples Center
in the world final awaiting them there
was Royal Club who's gonna win it 3-2
you're oil-free one pearl oil three one
one three zero royal thanks coach no
thanks I'm going to oil
thank you money I appreciate you like
your SKT favorite but I think it's more
time for I'm gonna have to go ahead to
well as well the hype surrounding the
Chinese juggernaut was justified
they had unquestionably been one of the
most impressive teams at the tournament
[Music]
he's getting obliterated no coming in as
well turbot picks up a kill but they're
only going one way right now son taking
tons of damage Jersey pull this still JC
near as well lovely can he get away from
this one Topol comes down that's a kill
for the bait five four zero eight eight
rolls jian zhu zi g how was a killing
machine and was revered as one of the
best ad carries in the world for his
super aggressive and technical play
style from the backside surprise here
comes the babe kill for white son sunken
escape it's one they focused on Uzi but
look at him it's still alive he's down
somebody he stays alive
[Applause]
surely the Chinese favorite would ascend
their throne and truly become League of
Legends royalty but it wasn't to be
Baker's ready to go explosive cask is
ready we've seen get hooked in zombies
this got a crescendo up but immediately
he is going to go down and every Lane is
getting punished now because push up
against one after the other going down
[Applause]
to the inhibitor now this will be one of
the first to siege has been pretty
unstoppable to these guys right now they
go for damage poke they want the fight
they're not even really going for the
turret it's always the one to the hook
can they get the cast all the assault
force and they go into the fight they
give it up a baker that do domestic
agenda but they have the study found yet
he's gonna run away from this one will
fun to get called out is the
that world baby getting cards out
completely
they're just drooling like flies come on
Becky main loss God like he's gonna get
caught how the kick comes in impacts
gonna follow on through goal against get
back in floors if he's gonna get created
it's gonna get dropped down equalizer
was down in time though lose he gets
caught out he's in trouble
looks like who's he may make it out he
burns the class kids adore us then he
puts on the barrier now is back in the
lead strike they take him down those
weights coming from the back and lucky
tried man up the percentages - boy
season owes us the trouble but the Sun
is our message wimpy blades cutting it
out
balls most compact oh hey men is there
Tommy's in trouble he's gonna go down
big knees Thank You thousand turn and
look at the he's just you know he's like
whatever they whatever new I give a
triple kill tipping a five for one fight
SKT we actually have time for that it's
bigger stone for more and he could gets
the kill Busey backs the hell away from
that one doesn't want to follow that
there's a qss it makes it more dangerous
world doesn't care about fighting early
to jump in from impact the equalizer
lays out the red carpet but they're all
off prevent already
they'd answered in the fight Royals
health bars are just getting to Marlins
who's he on the outside true to do what
he can but it's not going to be enough
who these chased into the base and as
Damon Eve wipe some pretty ace the
Quadra the [ __ ]
you guys wasn't yeah we'll pick up the
kale but will it be the gentlemen
because look at the top light oh that's
how I know Pandu get a little antsy on
this or tries to get in with IRA he may
put himself for the water no White's
gets pumped up by straightness not even
White's can believe it whites took both
have my goddamn into his face off
because that could very well be the last
mistake they get to make SK Telecom they
are already itching their name on that
Cup they can smell it right now they're
gonna be going for the second inhibitor
turret there's already one down world
doesn't even have five people hair grows
on the slicing mouth so of course to go
in but he was strangled or it back head
they continuously get the fight big
league I jump the waters on them in
there now absolutely running for the
fountain this does not look good for
Royal this visiting then crescendo
catches all the limits a coma for in
fight they get on the bouncing SK
Telecom I'll just roll is through the
Nexus turrets are potentially going to
go down this could be a 20 minute game
for SK Telecom they will be the season 3
Wow
champion
yeah SKT didn't just beat royal they
annihilated them 3-0 to make history we
have to take a hats off that was an
absolute performance by SK Telecom
when the Chinese Titan finally bent the
knee SKT became Korea's first league of
legends world champions s katie's
landmark win at Worlds 2013 wasn't just
important for the team and its players
but for their region as well their
conquest signaled the realization of
Korea's potential on the world stage as
the region's previous best offerings had
collapsed under the growing weight of
expectations SK T's coronation in 2013
marked the organization's first step
towards establishing a dynasty and
ushered in the Korean age of dominance
and international league of legends a
declarative challenge that still has yet
to be answered by the rest of the world
today
[Applause]
Wow champions
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button